new clashes between
armenia and azerbaijan over the
breakaway region of nagorno-karabakh
this video released by the armenian
military
purports to show an attack on
azerbaijani tanks
but azerbaijan denied any had been
destroyed
while releasing footage of its own
firepower
each side is blaming the other for the
flare-up and
warning of the threat of a larger war
it is no secret that the first fire
including artillery fire was opened by
armenia
and the first to die were azerbaijani
servicemen azerbaijan gave a decent
response to the enemy
and the enemy could not move an inch
the outbreak of a large-scale war in the
south caucasus could have the most
unpredictable consequences
it could go out of the region's borders
and take wider volumes and threaten
international security and stability
these two former soviet states went to
war in the early 1990s
over nagorno-karabakh the region
sits in majority muslim azerbaijan
but its ethnic armenian population of
christians
rejected rule from the capital baku
a ceasefire was agreed in 1994
though never a peace deal violence
flared again
four years ago and in july but
sunday's clashes could end up being the
most dangerous since the war
for the first time azerbaijan has
recaptured significant territory
uh and even some villages and that's
that's going to prompt or
is going to compel armenia to respond
militarily so we're on an escalatory
ladder for
now for for in foreseeable future and
how high up the ladder uh the sides get
is gonna depend on how high the emotions
run in both azerbaijan and armenia
and then whether or not russia and
turkey and maybe the international
mediators which i used to be one of the
osce's mints group
are able to get the parties to calm down
and get back to the negotiating table
civilians paying the price for what
armenians say
was azerbaijani shelling on the main
city in nagorno-karabakh
a new conflict could also impact global
oil and gas supplies
that flow through this region the
international community is calling for
calm
but armenia and azerbaijan have imposed
martial law
in a sign of growing crisis
debra haynes skinnies